yoli asks before you had an assistant
how did you structure your day the only
first of all I just want to tell you I
appreciate all the interaction thanks
for being a supporter of the askgaryvee
show by the way back to the last
question the middle is dangerous pre
assistant I mean it was a disaster
I had this power position at Wine
Library where I was one of the biggest
wine buyers in the world were definitely
in the u.s. in the world and and not
gonna got to my head but I was like look
somebody could wait 15 minutes or 20
minutes if I'm like you know finishing
up this meeting they're here to sell me
so I kind of took that you know the
buyers approach mentality to that but
was bad was I would triple booked people
like literally I used to be like on the
floor at 11:30 in the morning helping
somebody with you know a big selection
for a party and I'd see like somebody
walk in and be like oh yeah that's right
I have a meeting with Craig and I'd be
like yeah and you should try this Pinot
Noir and then I'd be like oh crap why
did Frank just come in that's right I
have a meeting with Frank and I think
it's at the same time that's bad let me
figure out what I'm gonna do and by the
way you need a little cheese for your
party why did Sally just walk in holy
crap I'm triple booked and this would
happen a lot and it was complete chaos
it was disorganized it wasn't efficient
and it was piss-poor oh crap wait
subscribe
I need subscriptions because I can't
push this many right hooks in social so
subscribe